change the change that it made was not
however to just buy steak for the
soldiers it was to buy the cheapest cuts
available and try and make them look
like steaks so the native Center began a
project trying to simulate the taste and
appearance of what are called whole
muscle cuts and they call these things
fabricated meats in there now known as
restructured meats that went on through
the 1960s and involves several different
innovations from new flaking equipment
to the invention of meat glue by Oscar
Mayer to understanding of how muscle
fibers work and finally just a figuring
out of the the right chemicals to add to
keep it juicy but in the mid-1970s they
were giving men and women in the field
fabricated or restructured veal steaks
pork chops lamb chops and these steaks
well you can imagine who also would like
a technology that makes sort of a
something out of nothing
it's the fast food industry so both
again through journals and conferences
as I talked about before and actually
through the some of the contractors
who'd worked on that project that
technology quickly found its way into
the fast food industry and in 1981
McDonald's debuted its McRib and an
interesting note on this is that the
original McRib was not well liked in
fact customers were so suspicious of it
that they refused to eat it and
McDonald's had to actually give it away
to get people to try it at the beginning
however this whole idea of the
restructured meat really caught on in
the food industry for the obvious
reasons and so it's made huge inroads at
the grocery store and now many of the
items that you can purchase in the
refrigerator case and the freezer are
restructured so that would be anytime
you buy something and there's a patty or
a cutlet or a nugget or if it looks like
it's been a little too neat and formed
oh and also in the deli aisle those are
restructured meat products
in fact this whole development of this
cheap way to to prepare protein has
presided over an increase in the amount
of meat that Americans eat from the
1950s of sixty pounds while the price
has dropped okay the list goes on and on
and some of the items are over here on
the table and if you want you can come
up and ask me about some of the things
here that I do talk about in the
presentation there are many more recent
things something called high pressure
processing and I'm happy to talk about
this with you in the book I bring the
reader on a supermarket tour and then I
try and estimate what the supermarket
would look like if I removed all the
items with the military influence or
origin and I estimate that the store
would be half empty ok well so what
right that's a fair enough but I think
there are several reasons why we might
not want to eat like special ops I'm the
first is that as we talked about these
are foods that the Army has developed
for very special and extreme situations
and they have these certain set of
values which are imperishable 'ti
durability affordability and broad pal
ability at their core those aren't
necessarily the values that we consumers
want to be at the core of our foods to
achieve that the foods often rely on a
lot of chemical additives and the use of
all sorts of ingredients which are there
solely to act as shelf life systems
things like emulsifiers thick and IR
thickeners and stabilizers while all
these ingredients have grass status
generally recognized as safe
many of them are synthesized in the lab
and few if any have be tested and when
consumed in small quantities and for
long periods of times and for effects
beyond cancer
and genetic mutations mutations and
finally there's there is emerging
research that shows that some of them
and have been linked to poor health
effects for example emulsifiers and BPA
have been linked to diabetes and obesity
at the end of combat-ready kitchen I
tried to imagine another food system
what would the supermarket looked like
if long-term human health and
environmental sustainability were all so
front and center in developing combat
rations I don't know but I am optimistic
that if we can make sure that the army
consider those values going forward
that we will end up with better options
in the supermarket
thank you well I am I am never eating
again that's for sure I have a couple of
questions I want to thank anastacio
because that was just fascinating in as
you listen to her your mind starts to
real doesn't it with the with all the
implications for for packaged goods that
we now take we take it for granted we
take for granted that there are things
like packaged cookies and packaged bread
and packaged cereal bars and drinks and
pouches it's just fascinating I hadn't
really thought about it until I read her
book I have a couple questions for you
and then we're gonna open it up to the
rest of you all so I say this at least
twice one of the well now we do have the
books for sale the book is wonderful
I've been reading it progressively over
the last class of the last week or so
and I have to say for a pretty dense and
serious topic it's fun I mean it she is
a fun writer and one question I have is
that there's a lot of science in this
book where did you where did you learn
all your science questions because it
gives me an opportunity getting my
soapbox well and that is I learned it
reading the book and I just I you know I
don't have a science background and I
realized that for me to really
understand what was happening here I
would have to master the science and I
just plunge and okay there's another
factor here which is I my book ended up
being signed by a provocative science
label so I had to kind of like until
then I thought of myself as a food
writer but that it was a really
wonderful experience and I realized that
anybody can wade right in and and really
master the most technical papers you
know a little help with with googling
terms and I use Wikipedia a lot to kind
of help me understand the basics but I
just you know acquired it on the fly but
it also made me realize how little
science we Americans really understand
what a huge deficit that is and how
especially in really understand
our role in relationship to relationship
to Modern Life we need to beef up our
science one of my favorite parts of the
book was reading a chapter that was
about Cato during the expansion of the
Roman Empire and how Cato basically
figured out how to make him and it took
centuries later for people to figure out
why actually that work but he has this
whole process which Anastacio has in the
in the book which is you take all that
you take all the hindquarters of the of
the pig you cover each one was solved
you put one on top of the other after
two weeks or so you rotate them so the
one that was on the top goes on the
bottom and you keep up and and it was
kind of fascinating to then in the book
she describes exactly what's going on
why does that work why is it that it
works to put all this halt in and a
further tidbit for me was to learn that
that the Roman Empire come essentially
controlled the salt industry which I
also didn't know I thought that was just
just full of tidbits like that the part
about the Aztecs being cannibals new to
me and so I have a question for you one
of the issues when the US was was
launching into the great military
upswing that was world war ii and
essentially taking in 11 million
soldiers was that everybody was too
skinny that they were undernourished at
the the fighting force is undernourished
now we have the opposite problem and
it's called that too fat to fight
problem how do you think too fat to
fight and the the Armed Forces sort of
consciousness about the food and the
health and the nutrition of their
soldiers now not just the calories but
the whole the whole corpus that goes
along with eating healthy food how do
you think that'll change the industrial
food transfer from Army to to the
civilian world and back well first of
all I think that the military has some
responsibility I mean I one of the
reviews of the book said the military is
making you fat now
I don't necessarily go that far but I
think that there is definitely a
contribution by the development of these
foods that as we talked about include a
lot of non-food ingredients and aren't
very healthy in the Army's defense again
combat rations are intended to be eaten
for a short period in very special
circumstances so then when we take you
know when we have consumer foods that
are based on them those not-so-healthy
characteristics end up being absorbed in
the general population the army I don't
know how the Army is handling the
obesity issue I know it's you know it
done it's doing some things to eliminate
trans fats and certainly has more
concerned about salt and sugar and the
ration but I I don't know if that's
doing any specific initiatives around
that let's open it up if there are any
questions from the audience
I'm full of questions I can keep going
in the back there there are two got the
Natick lab going how Natick was chosen
and why need it why is it in a deck oh
that's you know that is a so glad you
asked that question because as being in
Massachusetts that's incredibly
important and that is because pretty
much MIT and MIT was a huge collaborator
during World War Two in all sorts of
science including food science and
really something really interesting is
that actually MIT was the founder of one
of the first to food science programs in
the United States and it was one of the
leaders in food science up until the
1980s and they dismantled their program
entirely and you know I kind of under
this slightly weird circumstance but
perhaps because the funding had was
diminished but they had a very
very big role in food science up until
that time so how did they get from the
glass canning to the tin canning that we
so often okay that that's not small
actually the small detail I'm glad you
brought it up obviously um glass might
have some issues especially if you're
gonna be a soldier on the March and what
happened was that immediately following
a parish discovery someone across the
channel guy named Peter Duran invented
the tain the cam and applied that whole
process of canning to the tin can and a
fun note is that the original tin can
factories they could only produce six to
ten cans per day these are handcrafted
tin cans and they were only purchased by
I think was the British and French
Navy's and they these four enormous
quantities of food another question
well I have a question the plastic
packaging that has sort of taken over
our world can I pin that on the the
military's you know in addition to the
swimmer and the pouches and everything
else can I like can I sort of dump that
it that the Army's doorstep I kind of
dump that at the Armory stores because
so they were this ones who first
envisioned you know replacing for
example cellophane with a pas synthetic
polymer and then the invention of the
retort pouch which I think this is a
terrible idea you're cooking food and
storing it in plastic for a long period
of time plastic there's something that I
didn't talk about in the in the
presentation but in the book plastic is
it basically melts and softens at 200 or
300 degrees Fahrenheit and when you
compare that to traditional materials
like ceramic and metal that's like two
thousand three thousand degrees okay so
every time you heat plastic little
pieces of it are getting into the food
and those are both what are called the
plasticizers which include things like
phalates and actual little pieces of the
polymer which are monomers to just kind
of go out so so food stored in plastic I
think is a pretty bad idea I'm really
hopeful that more work is done in the
development of bile polymers cover when
you microwave things to cover them with
plastic well that's not something I do
because I begin I'm I I'm I'm a little
bit more skeptical I think than the
average consumer but I I think it's a
very as much as you can to avoid cooking
and heating plastic and that would
include the microwave because the the
plastic if the plastic heats then then
it's going to be more more that mobile
questions in the back I'm fascinated by
this because I went somewhere and
Thanksgiving and had a brown in back
yeah that was cut to now Reynolds bag so
was that technology developed by the
military the sort of sort of plastic
that you can cook in at 375 for four
hours well because this allows me to say
how little ground I covered and it's
embarrassing because I feels like no but
I'm sort of like hey guys this is just
the tip of the iceberg and literally I
could see so many other topics when I
did my research the book took me three
years to write and research and there
are so many other things that I could
see and couldn't follow up and because
it would have taken me 20 years or I
couldn't in that moment do the little
sort of find the smoking gun that I
needed to really connect it to the
military but one of the things I do know
about and don't even didn't even you
know touch on in the book is the Army
has been very involved in the
development of equipment and restaurant
equipment and in fact coming down the
line is something they've figured out a
way to modularize cooking equipment and
that's gonna make a big opportunity for
fast food companies to spread out into
smaller regions where they don't have to
actually build a big restaurant you can
have a containerized modular kitchen and
like there is McDonald's out in the
Andes on you know in some sort of market
sir pans yeah and there's a yes there's
a huge amount of stuff that comes out of
the Army on that and I don't know all of
it I just know a little of it how much
connection is there between military
in school lunches prison system lunches
are they using the same methodology
differently people in quantity or is
that because of the extremes in
environment that the military underwent
that that was developed school lunches
in prison programs just jump on the
bandwagon with who was already being
developed in the military food well
there are two connections I can think of
right off and the first of course is
that you know there are what you're
talking about would be akin to some the
garrison feeding which is these big
stable camps where they have actual
kitchens and some of that equipment
might be used and some of the techniques
but again because there's so many areas
that I don't cover fully in the book and
one of them is transportation and
storage of items as well as food safety
and so all those things are going to
come into play and in school kitchens
and cafeterias so I just wonder if there
if there's some in your mind some
positive offsets that that come from
some of this technology for instance the
elope the smaller carbon footprint of
shipping say a truckload of something
that's packed in a septic cartons as
opposed to glass which is quite heavier
do those kind of positive offsets
make the math come out in favor of some
of the technology being used or I you
know what one of the things that people
have commented to me and I don't think I
necessarily went into reading in the
book this way but they said you know
ultimately this is a very fair book you
know I don't come out trash in the
military I think the military's doing a
good job at what they're supposed to be
doing
I do trash the FDA but that's a
different story but I do think there's
some benefits to these foods and I use
these foods I'm not kidding when I you
know I I my kids love energy bars I've
kind of tried to weave those X I think
there are low value food overall but
there are many convenience and processed
foods that I use and one of the things
it has done is it made me a little more
optimistic about the future of processed
foods because there's some and I'll just
but these two things have been developed
with something called high pressure
processing which was spearheaded by the
military in the late 1990s early 2000s
with a big consortium of that list of
the top 20 food and packaging companies
and what it does is it it sterilizes and
cooks food using really really intense
pressure in the book I compared it to 20
million stacked on a penny but what that
does is any microorganisms in the food
die and it cooks it very quickly but
maintains the texture fresh taste and
the vitamin and mineral content so so
far they haven't found any negative
health effects so this may be something
that we can use and feel a little bit
less guilty about when we serve it to
our kids yes I'm so glad this guacamole
is actually purchased on October 15th
and the scared what I was consuming
because it you can not finish the table
right next day it's still green well
this is a very should really try and get
more information to consumers because
the reason this guacamole stays green is
because it was high pressure processed
that high pressure processing it
inactivated the enzymes that turn
guacamole brown usually so this has
probably if it has a preservative is
about similar I think it's like citric
acid or something like that and it's
just this new processing technique it's
packed in is more harmful to us than the
product inside
the other actually Hormel had a huge
success with using this new high
pressure processing with a line of
preservative free deli meats and this is
one here the natural ham natural choice
those single-shot juices and smoothies
that people like high pressure
processing and off and sometimes for
entire prepared dinners we have to wrap
up but I have one last question for you
so of all of the all of the the
innovations the wonderful new products
that have come to us through this
process are there one or two for which
you are personally so grateful one or
two innovations that say without X&Y
sure I mean we can go way back and talk
about bringing over this actually also
came out of world war two active dry
yeast and if you are a home cook you
don't think that your food has a
military influence but it does and this
allowed yeast which is as you know a
living thing
to be sort of put into a state of
suspended animation so they could then
ship it overseas for use in those army
camp army Baker units that we talked
about
well thank you dude yeah I just wanted
to say so thank you for all for coming
yes I sitting in the front rows like I
know there's a bunch of people back
there and here you all are thank you so
much and thank you Louisa for bringing
this awesome
talking here I just wanted to give our
our pitch of the kitchen and we're so
glad to have folks like this come in
here into the kitchen we want to have
more folks learning stuff like this in
this spot and I'll tell you at first I
thought the maghreb looked delicious but
now all I want to do is go out and shop
that market which is all fresh food
that's been grown really close to here I
mean it's great to see that there are
folks you know utilizing these new
processes but go shop the market by this
book I just thought of four people that
I need to get it for so thank you so
much and please come back to the kitchen
to come back to the market we teach
classes here all the time so if you want
to learn how to make your own stuff and
not have to buy the packaged stuff we'd
love to have folks back here we've got a
sign-up sheet leave your name email
address you can learn about programs
here we also have I don't know how much
time you have but we have reserved the
meeting table that's outside in the
market so we unfortunately have a
meeting in here pretty soon so we're
gonna start wrapping up for that but
folks are welcome to go out there and
continue this conversation we reserved
that meeting table for this discussion
so that's my schpeel
[Applause]
the book is fun to read fun to read
thank you so much on this example we
take you to c-span real quickly for
questions so
[Music]
you're watching book TV on c-span -
television for serious readers here's a
look at what's on primetime tonight we
kick off the evening with Ryan Owens the
University of Wisconsin professor
explains the role of the office of the
Solicitor General in the Supreme Court
then at 7:45 Roger Lowenstein takes a
look at the creation of the Federal
Reserve and at 8:45 Millan viveur and
Kim has a rally discuss women in
leadership at 10:00 Mei Fong sits down
for book TVs afterwards program to talk
about China's recently discontinued
one-child policy with the New Yorkers
Evan Osnos and directly following
afterwards at 11:00 David Bernstein
argues that the Obama administration has
undermined the Constitution that all
happens starting next on c-span 2's book
TV first up on book TV in primetime Ryan
Owens
and now next on book TV
Solicitor General in the United States
Supreme Court there's the book cover
co-author is University of Wisconsin
professor Ryan Owens professor Owens
what is the Solicitor General so the
Solicitor General is the attorney for
the United States he or she represents
the United States interest in the
Supreme Court occasionally in the
federal circuit courts of appeals but is
is really the the central figure in
terms of litigating the u.s. is
positioned before the Supreme Court
whether or not that person is an expert
in the topic being discussed or not it's
more of a trial attorney type thing well
so that that's a good question
so the the office of the Solicitor
General sort of has three layers to it
at the very top we've got the the US
Solicitor General now Don Verrilli
that's a position that is nominated by
the president confirmed by the Senate so
these typically are people who are very
very good in the legal sense but also
well-connected politically so below them
then you've got four deputy solicitors
general and those are folks who are
experts in the issue area that's
involved and then below them of course
you've got the the staff attorneys so
what's unique about the SGS office is
cases that that with which they're
involved start off with the staff
attorneys who are generalists and they
investigate the case they do their
research and they write as a generalist
judge would want to read write not full
of jargon and things that are
technically specific it'll get kicked up
then to that next level of the the the
deputy solicitors general who are issue
experts so they review the case and then
they'll kick it up to the to the
Solicitor General so each each one of
these briefs and the presentations that
they're going to make gets filtered
through generalist
to expert in the issue area back up to
generalist again so the kind of language
that comes out of the office the kind of
presentation that comes out of the
office is really quite unique because it
gets filtered through so many different
channels so when you asked about you
know the Solicitor General preparing or
presenting a case
whether he or she is an expert in many
instances the answer to that question is
no they're just surrounded by good
experts and people who can make very
logical reasonable arguments and I think
that's in large part what explains their
victory where did the term come from
yeah well so the the term solicitor
general has been around for a long time
but the office itself hasn't been so by
way of background I think the evolution
of the Solicitor General's Office is
really interesting and this does a
promise connected to the the question
about the name but one of the first
pieces of legislation Congress passed
was in 1789 and it was called the
Judiciary Act of 1789 did a lot of
really important things but it created
the the position of the Attorney General
right the Attorney General at that point
was a cabinet officer and he was charged
under the Act with with doing two things
the first was to give legal opinions to
members of the cabinet other people
within the federal government so if you
want to know whether or not you think
something is constitutional you know
when Congress is thinking about passing
it you asked the Attorney General right
and we see that today in many states the
AG's still provide opinions on things of
that nature but the second thing acted
is it charged the Attorney General with
appearing before the Supreme Court on
behalf of the United States great so as
the country expanded the Attorney
General just got inundated with requests
from cabinet members on just to answer
legal questions about things basically
who couldn't keep up with all of the
work so what Congress decided to do was
allow the Attorney General to hire
private attorneys to litigate on behalf
of the United States now as you can
imagine this became a nightmare in terms
of costs in terms of just controlling
the messages that came out of these
attorneys it was just a nightmare
scenario so what Congress did after the
Civil War is it asked the Attorney
General sort of taken accounting of
things where do you stand with your work
you know do you have sufficient staff
laughs members and the Attorney General
at the time said in terms of staff
members and you know writing the legal
opinions for people in the cabinet we're
okay we're doing a good job there but we
really have a problem keeping up with
litigation on behalf of the United
States and the Supreme Court so what the
Attorney General at that point did was
ask Congress to to give him an assistant
and said boy it sure would be really
nice if I could have somebody called the
Solicitor General who would help me
argue my cases before the Supreme Court
and so what Congress did is they you
know they actually paid attention to
what he wanted and in 1870 they passed
some legislation and what's interesting
about it is it so they allow the
Attorney General to to hire somebody who
would be learned in the law was the
language that they used and what's
interesting about that is previous to
this that phrase learned it in the law
was something that was attached to the
Attorney General
anybody who wanted to be an attorney
general had to be confirmed but also had
to be deemed as learn it in the law and
when Congress passed this act in 1870
they shifted that expression from the
Attorney General over to the Solicitor
General which again emphasized the fact
that we want this person to litigate in
the Supreme Court is there a sort of a
fascinating history on the passage of
this legislation - and as we detail in
the book the Solicitor General wins like
crazy I mean the Solicitor General wins
I think I put in there something to the
effect that like the Green Bay Packers
in the 1960s the SG rarely loses right
you can probably say the same thing
about Aaron Rodgers today but anyhow so
the SD this really wins quite a bit but
what's remarkable about this is that
when Congress was debating the
legislation and sort of figuring out
what we want to do here their biggest
concern was on saving money and I'd
mentioned earlier that all of this
business was about hiring private
attorneys and it got costly and what
Congress really wanted to do when they
created the Solicitor General was to
save money and surely they did that
they didn't have to hire out for private
attorneys all the time but they created
this institution that has just been
remarkably successful now clearly they
wanted something that would be
successful but to see how it went from
being focused so heavily on cost savings
to now this institution that we have
which is just so remarkably successful
is one of those times where you have
perhaps unintended consequences that are
actually quite good why does it have
such a high success rate yeah sort of
general's office well you know that's a
good question so really with the book we
had two goals the the first was to
figure out whether or not the Solicitor
General can actually influence what the
court does and our second goal was to
figure out okay if there is influence
what's the what's the causal mechanism
there you know if we turn to the first
approach the first question that was
sort of the predominant question in the
book up until we wrote this book there
was a lot of you know very good
scholarship out there that showed that
the Solicitor General's office wins a
lot we're talking about sixty to seventy
percent of the time when the SG is a
party to a case when the Solicitor
General appears as a sort of a friend of
the court and files an amicus curiae
brief that success rate actually is
quite a bit higher than that you know it
can be in some instances you know it was
a hundred percent in some court terms
well what we wanted to do was say okay
there's a lot of evidence of success
there but that doesn't necessarily imply
influence write a solicitor general
could be winning all kinds of cases for
reasons that have nothing to do with
influence right maybe you know what the
court wants to hear so you just say that
so for us the the real motivation was to
try to figure out are there conditions
under which this attorney for the US can
get justices to do things they wouldn't
otherwise have done right so to do that
our goal was to look at a number of
different stages in the decision making
process and specifically what we wanted
to do was say all right let's take an
attorney who's arguing a case on behalf
of the u.s. well let's see if we can
compare him or her
to other attorneys in similar cases with
similar backgrounds but who didn't argue
on behalf of the United States right so
we want to do is is match these people
so that they're as similar as we can
possibly get them to be except for one
is arguing from the Solicitor General's
Office and the other is not right and if
we can find that well sort of holding
everything else sort of the same right
if we find that one actor wins more than
the other for us that suggests that
there's a strong degree of influence
there and and that's what we observe
throughout this decision-making process
so if you look particularly at just
whether the Solicitor General's Office
wins or loses so if we take attorneys
who are otherwise identical except in
one case you've got somebody arguing for
the Solicitor General in the other case
it's just like a private attorney we
find that the Solicitor General's office
is about 14% more likely to win than the
other attorney right and again this is
while holding everything else almost
identical right so in other words 14
times out of a hundred the SGS office is
gonna win just because they're arguing
in the SGS office all right so you said
what explains this that was a question
that you had asked well when we matched
all these folks that they were as
similar as possible what we tried to do
was get at existing theories of
Solicitor General success one of these
theories for example it just turns on
experience how often have you argued
before the Supreme Court before and you
might assume reasonably that the more
you've argued before the court the
better you are added the more confident
you are at it and therefore the more
likely you are to win right so we
decided let's try to match people and
see how much experience you've had
arguing before the court and it turns
out that the experience level doesn't
really explain the Solicitor General's
success yes solicitors general are more
experienced arguing before the court but
when you compare them to private
attorneys who are just as experienced
they still win more often the Solicitor
General does so we tested things like
that like the
the amount of experience you had the
resources you had whether there was a
separation of power is component to this
and at the end of the day all of those
things didn't matter you know I should
say none of those things mattered but
what seems to matter more than anything
is the Solicitor General's objective
reasonable approach to cases s jeez
don't push the political boundaries too
far with the court right they understand
that they're going to come before the
court again in the future
and their credibility is on the line so
what they wind up doing is sort of
walking a won't they do a balancing act
right yes their presidential loyalists
right the Solicitor General are but
they're also advocates before the
Supreme Court all the time
so have they have to tailor their
message they have to moderate if they
get pushed too far by a political
president right they're gonna moderate
their position when they go before the
Supreme Court and I think that fact
along with just sort of the consummate
legal professionals that work in their
office I think that's what drives their
success more than anything how and why
does the u.s. become a party to a court
case
sure well there are lots of different
ways that this can happen chief among
which is just the u.s. getting sued by
someone so if the US does something that
an individual thinks violates his or her
statutory or constitutional rights you
know they are allowed you know it's a
file suit in federal court and you know
I take that up to the Supreme Court if
you know if it's a case that's worthy of
it there are other instances in which
the United States can get involved so
the the primary one there just being a
party to the case but then as I
suggested earlier there is this notion
of being an amicus curiae participant so
that's when the the government is not a
party to the case but has an interest in
the outcome of the case in those
settings the Solicitor General will get
involved if the United States wants you
know if the administration wants the SG
to get involved
and they can file what's called a friend
of the court brief then and get involved
in that capacity Don Verrilli current
Solicitor General right in fact a well
known name yep in Washington the
Solicitor General's become quite
well-known look at Attorney General has
that always been the case well known
when he was with the bush that's right
that's well I think among those circles
you know the legal elite circles the
Solicitor General is always really well
known but you know it's kind of weird to
examine the evolution of figures over
time as the media has become more
widespread and you know and now with
social media having such the force that
it does if you take a look for example
at just the behavior of justices and
they have followings today that that one
never would have thought of before now
Felix Frankfurter when he was on the
court he had a following just because he
had so many former law students who own
going into practice and so he was sort
of the rock star of the time right but
now if you look at it you can see
Justice Scalia has such a following for
people Elena Kagan seems to have one as
well and if you go and you actually look
at the justices financial disclosure
reports and see them where they're
traveling who they're speaking to you
get a really interesting sense of sort
of what's motivating these folks you
know maybe it leaves you with questions
about why are they traveling to some
places versus others but the the bottom
line is it you know we've seen that
evolution with justices I think we've
also seen that with solicitors general
they sort of take on a following as well
you know and the thing about Don
Verrilli is you know he was a as you
suggested a a pretty well known
respected advocate before he got to the
Solicitor General's office and I
remember listening to the arguments in
the Affordable Care Act case and the the
Arizona immigration case and thinking to
myself but this guy is not doing well at
all
I mean I think most people who listen to
those oral arguments thought that he got
his tail kicked by the justices and I
remember you know turning off the the
oral arguments and thinking to myself
well this case is really much more
interesting
right but then I had to stop and think
for a couple of days all right well what
does our book say about this right well
the book says the SG is gonna snatch
victory from the jaws of defeat and and
honestly I think he did that in these
cases if it if that had been any other
attorney thing who gave the kind of
performance he did I'm not sure they
would have won that case but because
this is somebody arguing on behalf of
the US I think they're able to get away
with for lack of a better expression
more than than other attorneys would
does the Solicitor General's Office have
any other duties besides it's kind of
laser focus on Supreme Court cases yeah
they have some duties so one of the
primary things is just sort of
incidental to the Supreme Court
litigation but but really is quite
important so they've got the duty of you
know representing the US but there's
also this Duty of centralization and
coordination see one of the biggest
problems the u.s. faced in addition to
the costs before we had the Solicitor
General was the fact that individual
agencies whether they hired private
attorneys are not they would take
different legal positions in cases which
is to say that you could have the same
federal statute and you might have one
agency take one position in in a case in
a different agency take the totally
different position right so you can
imagine and that causes confusion for
justices it causes confusion you know
what is the position of the United
States who knows so when the SG comes
around one of the other duties that he
that he performs is this duty of
centralization and coordination you
can't appeal if you're the u.s. you
can't appeal a loss to the Solicitor
General to the United States Supreme
Court unless you get the SGS permission
to do so you can't file an amicus curiae
brief at the Supreme Court without first
getting the Solicitor General's
permission to do so and if the SG does
grant permission then he or she or
someone in the office there is going to
be heavily involved with that case so by
virtue of sort of almost playing you
know the coordinator or a veto it
the SG can really help influence what
the u.s. is position is a case and and
and this is a pretty important power if
you talk to former SGS they'll say
things like oh I remember one time we
had the FCC that wanted to take one
position you know and the NLRB wanted to
take the other one and it was up to me
to figure out which position was gonna
be the policy of the United States so
you know to that extent I think you can
you can see the power of the Solicitor
General particularly if the president
faces say a Congress that that he
doesn't get along with right maybe
rather than going through Congress and
trying to pass legislation you use your
Solicitor General to go before the court
and enact policy change one way or the
other
there so you know those are the two
responsibilities I think is the
representation and then the coordination
and that really is an important
prerogative for the SG is the SG
independent of the Attorney General
that's a good question
I'm going to say by and large the SG is
independent of the Attorney General now
technically speaking the Attorney
General is the SGS boss right and so in
large part this does depend on the
personality of the Attorney General and
the president how much independence they
want to give to the Solicitor General
but most presidents most attorneys
general are sympathetic to that
independence they I think they value
that independence for a couple of
reasons one they probably recognize that
that independence helps them win more
cases before the court because justices
find them to be more credible and the
other is presidents probably value
people who say no from time to time all
right or at least they ought to if
you're surrounded by people who are you
know involved in groupthink they always
just agree with everything that you say
and then here comes this in the
independent actor who says you know you
can't really make that argument in court
I think presidents value that kind of
information because they just like
justices know that it's credible it's
coming from a reasonable source so there
have been instances where attorneys
general I think have tried to push the
SG a little bit but more off
not presidents and in cabinet members
are willing to defer to the Solicitor
General in fact I recall in the 1990s
there was a federal court that struck
down I think it was portions of NAFTA or
WTO something like that and the Clinton
administration waited to put out a
position on it until after they had
heard from their Solicitor General and
to me that that suggests a high degree
of credibility and deference paid by the
President to the SGS office book TV is
on location at the University of
Wisconsin in Madison we've been talking
with political science professor Ryan
Owens and here's his co-written book the
Solicitor General and the United States
Supreme Court many of this year's
presidential candidates have written
books to introduce themselves to voters
and promote their views here's a look at
some in his newest book reply all Jeb
Bush catalogues his email correspondence
during his time as the Florida Governor
presidential candidate and former
neurosurgeon ben Carson argues a better
understanding of the Constitution is
necessary to solve America's pressing
issues in his latest book a more perfect
union and former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton looks back on her time
serving in the Obama administration in
hard choices in a time for truth Texas
senator Ted Cruz talks about his journey
from a Cuban immigrant son to the US
Senate Carly Fiorina former CEO of
Hewlett Packard shares lessons she's
learned in rising to the challenge
former Arkansas governor Mike Huckabee
gives his take on politics and culture
in God Guns grits and gravy and Ohio
Governor John Kasich calls for a return
to what he sees as traditional American
values and stand for something Kentucky
Senator Rand Paul calls for smaller
government and more bipartisanship and
taking a stand more presidential
hopefuls with books include Florida
Republican Senator Marco Rubio and
American Dreams he outlines his economic
plan independent Vermont senator Bernie
Sanders has updated his 1997
autobiography
now titled outside we're in the White
House to include his time in the Senate
and the launch of his presidential
campaign in blue-collar conservatives
Rick Santorum says the Republican Party
must focus on the working class in order
to retake the White House
Donald Trump has written several
bestsellers his newest book crippled
America outlines his political platform
Carrie Johnson is the presidential
candidate for the Libertarian Party and
seven principles of good government he
discusses his political philosophy and
his time as governor of New Mexico and
finally Governor Chris Christie and
former governors Martin O'Malley and Jim
Gilmore have announced their candidacies
but haven't released books book TV has
covered many of these candidates and you
can watch them on our web site book TV
org
and now on to tonight's guest
Roger Lowenstein has reported for The
Wall Street Journal for more than a
decade including for its stock market
column heard on the street and the
intrinsic value column his work has
appeared in publications ranging from
the New York Times magazine to Bloomberg
currently Loewenstein maintains a column
for the magazine smart money he has
written several books including the
bestseller buffett origins of the crash
the end of Wall Street and tonight's
topic of discussion America's Bank and I
do want to let you know he let me know
that there's a great review of it coming
out in the Washington Post tomorrow so
we can read about that tomorrow yes
three children and lives with his wife
in Newton Massachusetts so please join
me in welcoming Roger Lowenstein
[Applause]
Debra thanks very much and it was a
wonderful
maiden introduction I'm glad I don't
have to talk about dinosaurs because I
don't know much about him I'll leave
that to the the next speaker what I'm
gonna do tonight is mostly talk to you
but I'm gonna read a few passages as
well that I hope conveys some of them
what I felt was the drama of the story
those of you who followed some of my
career might know that this was my first
history and for me it was really the
most exciting project I've ever been
involved in because the the people that
I wrote about reminded me so much of
people on the scene today and the book
is full of controversies that feel like
they left off the front pages of today
in fact just last night anyone who saw
the Republican debate may have seen the
Ted Cruz you know came out against the
Federal Reserve and advocated of the
system of going back to goal based money
and presumably not having a Federal
Reserve tonight I'd like to tell you
what it was like when we actually had a
system like that back 100 years ago but
before I get to that I want to start
with something more simple and basic
which is what is a Federal Reserve and
and why do we have it today if you think
about an ordinary bank you know they
they serve two functions which are kind
of self-evident for people who don't
have enough money they're places they
can go and borrow and for people who
have surplus they can go and park it and
earn interest but besides helping out
those two groups of people they serve a
larger social function which is there a
way of getting money that would
otherwise just sit there in the you know
wherever rich people keep their extra
money in their basements or you know in
some safe and their yachts or something
and and move it to someplace where it's
useful to society where where to people
who actually have a need for it so it's
banks fulfill that social function a
central bank is just a banker to banks
just as some people have access funds
some banks have access funds they may
have a few extra billion dollars
flashing around
and they can park their excess reserves
in any one of a network of reserve banks
around the country which is what the
Federal Reserve is and obviously just
like some people are in need of funds
sometimes banks run out of money and
they can borrow from the Federal Reserve
and we saw that in a big way during the
financial crisis in 2008 and 2009 when
the Fed became the the classic role that
it was assigned for the lender of last
resort it's really important in a crisis
because what happens in a crisis is it's
not only the the sick banks that stopped
lending but the healthy banks when they
see other banks in trouble they say I'm
gonna pull back I better stop lending
and you get this this dynamic whereby
every bank does what it has to do to
protect itself to call in loans but
they're all doing something that hurts
the community at large that is to say
depriving the country of credit and the
the role of the central bank is to
so-called lien against the wind and lend
when when no one else is after the
mortgage crisis my editor suggested to
me that it might be interesting and fun
to look at what the country was like
before we had Federal Reserve and and
how we got one
so I plunged into archives and as I said
this is the first time that I've done
primarily or in this place exclusively
archival research and that's a really
different world from reporting there
were lots of things I couldn't do I
couldn't call up Woodrow Wilson and ask
him you know why he'd done such and such
and and so on it would have been a not a
very lively conversation but but I
discovered that there are things that an
asourian can do that or things get
revealed to a Nestorian that that might
not to a contemporaneous researcher the
the Federal Reserve Act the the peak of
the legislative process was in the
summer of 1913 Washington then like now
Washington DC was a very hot place to
live and work and Ellen Wilson the
president's rather delicate wife left
town for New Hampshire during the summer
which wasn't uncommon
for political spouses in that era and so
since she was in another town we have
the record day by day of what Wilson was
writing to her which committees in
Congress were giving him trouble which
congressman he was leaning on who who in
his cabinet was giving him trouble you
know today you wouldn't have that the
the first couple would be in the same
city or they'd be you know talking on
the telephone and so on in other ways
the ear of felt completely similar to
now it was a period of great financial
stress there was a financial crisis
people were very angry at the banks many
the banks misbehaved they were angry at
the government Ted Cruz has nothing on
the populace of the late 19th and early
20th century that they in that day and
age they were Democrats now they're you
know when the Tea Party wing of the
Republican Party but the feelings are
largely the same the people didn't like
big banks they didn't like Washington
and they didn't want Washington anywhere
near a big bank itself and I'm going to
tell the this story through the eyes of
one particular character who had to
confront these feelings and I say
confront because he was not an American
his name was Paul Warburg and he found
the attitudes of his adopted country
very bizarre to say the least but
Warburg would play a very big role in
the in the formation even though he was
not an American of the Federal Reserve
he would later write in his memoirs that
his hope was that the Federal Reserve
would become a great National Monument
as he put it rather poetically like the
great cathedrals of Europe and his life
was really one long struggle to try to
make that so he was born into a very
wealthy banking family in Hamburg in the
second half of the 19th century he had
the three or four brothers who were
involved in the family banking business
with him but he quickly became the heir
apparent and by his late 20s was a set
to run the family bank however that
point he fell
with the daughter of an American banking
family Nina lobe of the Kuhn Loeb
banking family they got married in
around 1899 1900 and Paul and Nina at
first settled in Germany but she wasn't
too happy living away from her folks and
long story short they relocated to to
New York very quickly after Warburg got
to New York he realized how different
the system in his adopted country was in
Europe all the banks had their reserves
in this central reserve in in America
each bank kept its own reserves
I say reserves I mean rainy day money
extra money and when I say kept their
own that keep them in their vault or
they might Park them in a bigger Bank
that paid a little higher interest down
the block so a bank in Tacoma might have
kept some of its reserves in a bank here
in Seattle and a bank in Seattle might
have then kept its reserves in a bank in
San Francisco but whenever there was
tightness this whole system would back
up the bank in in Tacoma would call in
its money from Seattle Seattle would
send a wire to San Francisco and you'd
get this money tightness and sometimes a
panic throughout the area and sometimes
throughout the country but believe it or
not there was this would happen to some
extent every fall when the harvest
season came in every farming community
and back then farming communities you
know held more than half the population
United States they were a very big part
of the economy the farming communities
would need cash to fund the harvest to
pay field hands
finance equipment grain houses all of
that cash would drain out of the cities
and there would be a mini panic rates in
New York would go up to a hundred
percent sometimes and Paul Warburg saw
this very soon after he emigrated to the
United States and he was absolutely
astonished and I want to take you now to
to an episode that shows his reaction
right after he moved to New York
Warburg was shocked by the primitiveness
of American Finance whereas banks in
Germany functioned with near military
cohesiveness banking in America he
concluded suffered from an ethos of
extreme individualism as credit
tightened each bank pulled its loans
thereby accentuating the scarcity for
all the rest in 1903
soon after a plunge on Wall Street
Warburg led on to Jacob Schiff his
brother-in-law and the senior partner at
Kuhn Loeb Warburg firm that he had
penned some thoughts on the defects of
American banking and how to cure them
the key problem that Warburg outlined
was the lack of a central reserve Schiff
read Warburg's paper and agreed with the
substance of it
however shift said Warburg had misread
the psychology the American people who
would never accept any institution
resembling a central bank he warned his
junior partner not to share his paper
with others but as a teaching exercise
for protege he offered to show the paper
on a confidential basis to a well-placed
friend James a Stillman who is president
of the National City Bank forerunner of
today's citi bank and one of the
prominent bankers in New York a day or
two later
Warburg looked up from his desk and
found Stillman looming over him Stillman
was a man of legendary licinus ism
highly eccentric he was silent now
looking at Warburg who half-closed heavy
eyes finally adopting a tone of gentle
sarcasm Stillman spoke how was the great
international financier he added
somewhat defensively Warburg don't you
think Citibank has done pretty well
Warburg agreed that it had very well
indeed why not then leave things well
enough alone
Warburg hesitated to reply he knew how
powerful mr. Stillman was finally though
he said your bank is so big and so
powerful mr. Stillman that when the next
panic comes you will wish your
responsibilities were smaller Stillman
went off in a huff the Warburg went back
to his work Warburg had stumbled on what
was really the original America